it was back in 2013 Aereo doing a little
bit of work for a change and he noticed
that I went back and forth with Chris
Mannix and we're talking about the 2013
draft the Cavaliers had the number one
pick and Anthony Bennett out of UNLV he
was the kind of guy that I could watch
you an lb play and not know he was on
the floor
but he kind of came out of nowhere and
he was a hot prospect and the Cavs were
you know gonna take him number one
overall this is how it sounded 2013 here
on the Dan Patrick show yeah I don't
know about the pick but you know coming
off shoulder surgeries packed on 2025
would you I would have taken all the
depo oh you're crazy you're I want you
to somebody save this recording and save
that one cuz all the depo to me
I think he's overrated I really do I
mean I think he's a good player if
you're picking in the 10 to 12 range but
the fact that Orlando passed up on Ben
McLemore for Victor Oladipo just boggles
my mind
okay Wayman how about we have a bet for
dinner who becomes an all-star first
Anthony Bennett or Victor Oladipo I'll
even take you one step further I'll say
Ben McLemore or Victor Oladipo I'm not
oh no no what just our bed so Chris
Mannix never paid up on the bat but
Mannix joins us now Mannix got anything
to say you know there are occasions that
I make good predictions when when not
none come to mind by the way your
t-shirt says Spain is stacked that goes
back to another one of your great
predictions you were anti-american back
then when you said Spain was going to
take the gold medal I think right I just
feel like the US team back in 2012 was
being given the magic carpet ride to the
gold medal yet to watch out for the
Gasol brothers that's all I was
transected Pauley do we have any moments
where Mannix had a good prediction not
yet okay all right well there's still
time
still time Chris but yeah if you want to
pay up on on dinner sometime if we get a
chance to get together you know what
you just ship some steaks here and then
all have dinner here and you have dinner
there so we'll have dinner together yeah
we can all Vermont is open den we'll
come on
so we're getting closer to the bubble
and as Polly use the analogy it's like
when you're getting married like you get
engaged and then you spend all this time
of flowers and you got to have rehearsal
dinner and only that's what the NBA's
been doing now they're getting ready to
down walk down the aisle here now there
are real concerns here how confident are
you that this that that we have an NBA
champion this year I'm fairly confident
we will have an NBA champion this year
at this point I have no idea what that
process is going to look like I think
it's unavoidable to have significant
players shut down because of the
coronavirus I think it might be
unavoidable to have an entire team
decimated because of the spread of
coronavirus this isn't just conjecture
Dan as someone that covers boxing I'm
watching what Top Rank is going through
in Las Vegas in Nevada which is one of
the best commissions in sports in
instuments states and they're dealing
with fighters dropping out left and
right so I look at that as evidence and
I see a hundred and fifty people in a
top ranked boxing bubble versus a
thousand plus in an NBA bubble and I
just have to tune that you're going to
have outbreaks the questions gonna be
what's the NBA's breaking point at what
point will they say look we've got to
shut it down for two weeks take it back
up again but this has to stop
yeah I wonder about the help those who
come in and clean those who are cooking
like that those people aren't you know
they're not sequestered here they're not
quarantined and I won not about that
though Chris it's a fair question to
wonder and I mean look the NBA's got
that hotline set up which is basically a
rat line like you're just trying to you
know rat on people that are breaking
violations that's going to happen I mean
I just
I just can't imagine young people
abiding by quarantine rules every hour
of every day I just can't imagine that
ultimately happening so you've got to
try to police that as best you can but
that's another potential entry point or
possibility of having some kind of
infection pass into that bubbly really
we have to stop call I have to stop
calling it a bubble it's not a bubble
not with this many people yeah going in
and out of it the nets you know what
kind of concerns do you think the league
has of them actually fielding a team to
go to Orlando they'll feel the team but
it's gotten kind of goofy in Brooklyn
least in the mind of some of the people
I've talked to at the league level like
there are things you obviously
understand you understand Avery Bradley
dealing with a family issue trevor ariza
a custody issue even to be frank Davos
burton's who is on a team that's not
gonna win anything saying you know what
I got a 10 to 12 million dollar per year
contract coming my way this offseason
I'm not risking it to go there but you
have Nets players in DeAndre Jordan
Spencer Dinwiddie that are effectively
ruling themselves out of Orlando before
the team even travels to Orlando that's
something I think the league has has
something of a problem nobody's denying
that they're dealing with stuff right
now but you know evidence shows you know
after a couple of weeks players can get
past this and get back onto the court
the Nets who are a team by the way that
Rus not forget if they missed the
playoffs they keep their first-round
pick so you know a lot of people are
wondering if that's in the mind of
Brooklyn as they prepare to move forward
he's Chris Mannix senior writer for
Sports Illustrated if I told you that a
team that consisted of javale mcgee dion
Waiters Rajon Rondo and JR smith would
be competing for a championship this
year be the favorites for a championship
this year what would you have said I
would say you're nuts
you had told me at LeBron and Anthony
Davis were part of that as well I mean
it's outlook I don't think jr. is gonna
play yeah I look at the Lakers and
there's some depth at that guard spot I
mean Danny Green is a great playoff
performer you look at the plus/minus
numbers Dan Alex Caruso and LeBron James
like excellent together and Caruso's had
one of those quiet sort of semi breakout
seasons in LA junior to me is great
glass in case of emergency like that's
that's who you go to in case another
injury happens the McGee stuff though
like you know Rob kolenka spoke
yesterday and we still don't know the
status of Dwight Howard yet and it's
amazing but Dwight Howard will be a huge
loss to the Lakers I mean he was an 18
to 25 minute per game type of guy that
was playing excellent this year so if he
can't go that takes away some Lakers
interior strength it forces Anthony
Davis play out of position more than he
wants to that to me is just as
significant a question is a Bri Bradley
any star players bailing aside from the
ones that we've mean true star players I
know they have concerns but is any
anybody bailing no not that I know of
and you know it's the kind of thing you
check in with teams with all the time
but at least at the very highest of
levels it's all systems are go for those
top level players I do believe from
talking to different agents and teams
that there are still some you know
mid-level role tight players for
different reasons that are considering
not going but the the highest of level
guys they are also going you think we're
starting in four weeks yeah I mean look
I think yeah I I think it'll be
interesting to see what happens in that
quarantine period where NBA teams go
down there and they're in Orlando but
they're not in the bubble
you know just yet and you know by the
time you season starts could we see a
run on infections during a travel time
when teams are down there but I just
unless there is a massive outbreak then
the NBA is gonna start their season I
know it's costing a lot of money to be
down there I heard you know Brian wind
or say this the other day but it does
all 150 million dollars 1.5 million
dollars per day to go down there but
they'd lose so much more if they didn't
go through with this they would have to
effectively terminate their collective
bargaining agreement they'd have to
start them scratch next year because of
all the losses they're almost too big to
fail at this point thanks for being a
good sport
we appreciate you giving us content you
know thank you Chris yeah I'm not gonna
be your your bubble
correspondent Dan you were to me
yesterday how about a playoff prediction
Blazers Sixers in final whoa okay you if
you get one right I'll wipe out the
dinner bed
no but you also have to go back to a
previous vet where I get to host the
show and you sit in Pauly's chair uh
yeah I'd sit there not do anything
I mean I'm that confident I mean Bali
does it well okay all right well thank
you Chris
bye my god my Bubble Boy that's Chris
Mannix senior writers were illustrated
joining us
Spain is stacked Spanish stack